With almost 500
sessions in Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see
"BeyondCorp Beyond Google,"
then stay tuned, because
here is the rewind.
[JINGLE]
If you're a large scale
company with lots of employees,
devices, and
applications, then chances
are your IT department
talks a lot about security.
And it's understandable.
Given our technology
age, there's
lots of attack vectors
to your company's data.
This is why about
10 years ago, Google
decided we wanted
to get rid of VPNs,
deciding that no network
was actually safe,
and the only way
to improve security
was to evaluate each
request as it happened.
And this was the
beginning of BeyondCorp.
At its core, BeyondCorp is
comprised of three things
that the enterprise can control.
First, policies that let you
define what and who should
or shouldn't have access.
Second, the set of attributes
about the specific request,
giving you important context.
And third, applications and
data that need protecting.
With this in place,
BeyondCorp lets
us ask various security
questions per request
at various stages.
For example, is this
employee a real user?
Is the device they
are using known
or has it been compromised?
Is the network path vulnerable?
And finally, given
all that data,
should the user be allowed
to access the applications?
This is done through a
set of four main tools.
First, the identity tools,
which let you do things
like keep a database
of users, their job
roles, and their access
levels, along with the ability
to have secondary credentials
and short lived sessions.
Next, endpoint verification,
which boils down
to having a database
of your devices,
understanding what operating
systems are supported,
and what device
information can be
used to make access decisions.
Then there's the
Identity-Aware Proxy,
which allows admins to
configure which people have
access to which applications.
And finally, the
control engine, which
contains a list of
these items mashed up
with buckets of access
that allow for easy scale
to thousands of applications
in your environment.
But let's look at something
a little more specific.
Let's say an employee is sitting
inside Google's headquarters.
At the identity level,
we know it's Sofia
and they're logged in.
We know the MacBook, because
we have its device ID
and that it's running the
operating system that we trust.
We also know they're
coming from the right IP
and that it's a
corporate device.
So we know they can access the
data they need and the proxy
applies that policy.
This person on this
device has access
to the bug systems
and the admin tools.
What's interesting is how
this changes when Sophia
moves to the coffee shop.
We still know it's
Sophia, but they're
using their own tablet, which
we don't know anything about
and don't trust the
operating system.
Our rules engine then notes
that, in the current state,
Sofia can't access
the bug system.
But in that current
state, Sophia
can access some systems
like calendar and email,
giving us the right
level of access
to the person and security
to the corporate data.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube channel
for more great "Next
Rewind" content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]